a few episodes back in episode 22 we
talked about the movement to shut down
stem which had not just that hashtag
hashtag shut down stem but shut down
academia and a number of others as well
and spoke to how a focus on shutting
down science and his associated ways of
thinking is doomed it is certain to doom
our civilization so just another
follow-on to that before I move into
some of the other domains where be
seeing this Oxford well this is slightly
old news at this points a couple weeks
old Oxford is decolonizing degrees in
math and science you hear this yep
that's right Oxford and and this is not
the first time they've gone down this
absurd road let me pull it up okay yeah
you can show our screen now Zack as as
reported in The Times
the London paper Oxford University has
revealed plans to decolonize in quotes
it's maths and science degrees and will
allow students of any subject who have
been affected by the black lives matter
furor to seek lenient marking now if
that's not a game of all position I
don't know what is and you know maybe to
their credit they don't say only for for
by pocker people of color students of
color they say for anyone who's been
affected we will offer you we will offer
you the option to seek lenient marking
so I should point out it's a game Abal
position but it is also to the extent
that it just simply happens we are
hobbling our position relative to others
automatically so if we take something
like mathematics and we elevate people
whose marks are lower because they've
been busy with something else then what
we are doing is we are hobbling our
position in math now I don't frankly
know where math people end up in terms
of building civilization and innovating
new things they do but it's just it's
it's a little harder to detect where
they are because you know you can't
apply math directly it doesn't make
things but let's say you do this with
your engineering school we've actually
we see
I didn't pull it up but we received an
email this week as well from someone
who's getting their PhD in engineering
who is seeing a dissertation being
defended on basically the need for
social justice in engineering for that
work they will receive a PhD in
engineering for work advocating for
social justice ad activism in
engineering they will receive the
highest degree awarded in engineering
so that's capture right there do you
know what role engineering plays in
civilization and so the point would be
were you to have a diversity of
positions on this the engineering
schools that did not engage in this
would out compete those that did engage
in it the students from those schools
would be higher quality they would go on
to populate the world so the fact that
we are going to see increasingly that
this takes over the entirety of the
Academy there are no holdouts because
they can't be because power is being
used to make sure there are not that is
going to put the United States in any
other country that can't resist this
madness at a disadvantage we will then
be hobbled relative to our enemies that
don't play this game abroad and so the
question is we here is some you know
weird amalgam of just those who fall
prey to the bullying and the ideology
well I guess what I would say the
difficult lesson is that even those who
believe that they're advocating for
their interests in advancing this those
interests are very short-term even if
you come out on top you're on top on a
ship that you're setting up to sink and
so if this is not in anyone's interest
and that that's going to be a hard
message many people won't be able to
hear it but it is necessary that we shut
down this ideology in order that we
ourselves don't sink something that
would harm us all everyone the
protestors everyone so this is necessary
that we do this above the objection of
anybody who would stand in our way which
does not mean that we don't subscribe to
the idea that black lives are
undervalued that that's gone on too long
and that it's time for it to stop at
that level yes of course but at the
level of should we destroy the Republic
in order to make a statement about black
lives that is ambiguous or
worse now of course we shouldn't
everyone is depending on us not doing
that and just to to go full circle here
on the Oxford this I don't even know
where this term decolonizing began I'm
sure it's somewhere over in critical
race Theory you know theory space but
the idea of decolonizing maths and
Sciences by allowing lenient grading for
anyone who claims to have been affected
by their own activism effectively is
this is not the first time we've seen
this there are a lot of schools where
we've where we've seen a push for this
and we first saw it indeed at Evergreen
where the administration in fact caved
to almost all the demands that came
their way and accepted that students
should be should be evergreen there
weren't grades but assessed more
leniently and you know basically not
have credit stake in a way if the reason
that they had not fulfilled their
academic duties was because they were
too busy rioting actually right so this
is this is becoming yet another thing
that's standard in the playbook
[Music]